hey what's up guys welcome to winners on
a Wednesday my name is Samuel Leeds
sometimes people think that to be
financially free you need lots and lots
of houses you actually don't you only
need two or three houses to become
financially free if you do it in the
right way so this week I've got poor
ants are a tear on the show and they're
gonna be talking about how they are
making three thousand pound profit per
month from just two houses all right
great to have you on the show love you
here look you long overdue because we've
been I've been asking you for ages
yeah about coming on so you've got to
hate emmos that are making you 3,000
pounds a month that's that's pretty
incredible absolutely no and you've got
loads of other properties in the
pipeline and going through more on the
pipeline more go through the legals
right now more you know working with our
other Bank of investors helping those
guys getting forward as well so it's and
from those two properties how much money
did you end up leaving in or cracking
we've probably got no more than 50
across both of them so 25,000 pounds on
each property rough Lavely and making
three thousand pounds a month the return
on investment on that is just insane
it's off the scale and there's more
space and rooms in those to come to Jack
the figures up still further Oh so top
taught me through the story then so
what's your background how did you get
end up getting at the game into pop so I
suppose I got in property one other
about three years old parents were very
much of the ilk of barley refurb sell on
to the to the next yeah the next family
home yeah so I pretty much grew up
either in a caravan in a garden or in a
bedroom up a ladder or in a windowsill
with my mum wallpapering over the top of
me one thing like that yeah all the
other family owned property and then
what did you do when you left school so
I was an IT for a number of years so hot
so high tech telecommunications
broadcast as an engineer and later as a
trainer an instructor okay cool
and how did you guys meet them what was
the story there Soren Paul used to do my
racing
various circuits in the country and a
friend of my sister's was also motor
racing Martinek and she worked with her
and at one time in 1996 they had a bit
of a birth they may have for somebody
and we ended up getting to know each
other and it just went from there really
so when because I know when we met first
Paul mm-hmm
you were a business a business
consultant yeah and you're helping
people with their businesses I don't
think you had any property investments
then not there no well you were open to
the idea so what what happened how did
you guys come to the decision to start
investing in property what how did that
happen well it's a meeting you that kind
of lit the fire okay there's yeah and
just in the the business meeting we're
in your 20 minute sort of presentation
introduction like mmm there's a lot more
that wasn't waiting on them but I've
been reading yeah yeah in a casino whole
places yeah yeah I was boxed up that's
probably what like three four years ago
it must be must be three years so I
spoke and that and then we kind of
connection on Facebook yeah and you were
then sort of interested in property and
then what happened well we'd always
always work on our own properties or our
property journey with our family home
with a very similar to one that I grew
up in so we'd buy a place we'd do it up
we sell it on we move on and we
literally come out in the back end of
that and we were able to refinance that
and so you know seeing yourself they
were like right let's just let this
germinate and then we saw the advert for
the crash course yeah so came along to
the crash course you did
well I thought that one in the crash
almost did again at the crash course not
well a weekend where on your own very
romantic weekend so you enter the crash
course like as a date to us exactly I
said and what how were you feeling at
this point about but probably very
skeptical yeah what a weekend in my
husband used wanted to be with Paul and
it got to the afternoon I was very taken
by what I've heard throughout the day so
when you stir up any laughing after
lunch and said you know does anybody got
anything to say about the crash course
so far I sort of I said well actually I
thought it's gonna be romantic and week
my husband and I still what I didn't
sleep much if my brain was dispersing it
yeah the first night but I said to you I
really really enjoyed the call so far I
really loved your enthusiasm and I've
loved the information that you were
passing on so yeah yeah bring on the
next day so prior to the crash course or
I know Paul was interested in property
and his and your family being a being
reefer big and selling properties what
were you thinking about property is like
a business curious or what was your
thoughts about that say you're a bit
skeptical you know bought properties
down the muck lived in them and then you
know refinanced and then moved on to the
next big property yeah because we work
houses we love always let properties
yeah I mean my personal experience I
moved at home I only ever lived in one
home and moved out when I was 25 so yeah
I've not got any prior buying experience
within your family but you know what I
met Paul is different cured that yeah we
both love doing what we're doing is just
it just excites us it's a why happen for
you then Paul at the crash course what
strategy really excited you so I mean
yeah HMOs definitely just just the
ability and for us it's more than just
the bricks and mortar so the ability to
take maybe a tired property or something
that that's been a veneer family home
previously and turn it into something
that's going to give a lot of people are
really high-quality living space your
house is a really good quality you don't
you don't
although the way the way you speak
sometimes people could think that you
could imagine it wouldn't because it's
you take a property and even a cram in
as many rooms as possible but you
wouldn't you wouldn't feel that in the
property would you you get big
properties it's big properties is big
rooms
yeah it's communal space it's
high-quality kitchens and common areas
are really important to us because
there's something that sort of runs
underneath this there's a lot of bad
press about landlords and if you were
just to read the stuff online and the
comments that come online about our he
must be you know living in your ivory
tower mr. landlord actually no we're
just regular guys who want to put in
place the best living experiences for
people who choose to come and stand up
yeah absolutely simple as that
absolutely so you came on the crash
course and HMOs attracted ey HMOs why
was that the strategy that you wanted to
go down yeah I think it was the ability
to work with single units in you know
for us like you know quite large single
units and you know the returns that were
that were possible from that as well
yeah you know it's a numbers game
there's other strategies that you can
make more money on in a short period
time absolutely yeah
but for us this felt right you know
Ferrara and sort of as well is Hector
Mo's are highly regulated which puts
people off but because they're already
highly regulated like they're not I
don't think they're gonna get any more
regulated now so you know when you buy
HMO and you set it up properly you know
that it's a very safe long-term strategy
and also because of the regulations a
lot of people don't understand them so
once you understand how they work and
you've cracked it it's just I think it
open I mean I'm actively buying a lot of
light to us at the moment I can imagine
and again for us that duty of care comes
in though all other rigs are here
we'll finish a property to here yeah so
we'll put in the extra fire provisions
that you don't have to but we do yeah we
put in the extra emergency lighting you
don't always have to but we do yeah so
all the little extra mile isn't it oh
absolutely and that way you're covered
then so okay it's funny because
sometimes people think that in order to
be profitable with HMOs you need to cut
corners be a bit rogue but but that's
not the case at all for you guys is it
not at all and it comes back from the
feedback from our you know our rental
partners who say to us you know there's
a lot of growth in particular cities
across the north a lot of people getting
into this stuff yeah so in some areas
now it's a renters market yeah they have
the ability to choose the places in
which they want to live yeah so if you
want to live in a seventy square foot
box that hasn't been painted that hasn't
been updated it's got ropey old carpet
you know and an old furniture great but
good luck with that because the market
now is very much into fresh large modern
starvation
right so you want house and I'm gonna
ask you about how you found it in the
details of that shortly but that you've
got one house that's giving you you say
two thousand pound profit a month yeah
for a lot of people and they're not for
you guys but for a lot of people that
would replace a full-time income like
two thousand pound a month on one house
if is its financial freedom for a lot of
people so would you be able to just talk
me through I know you've done some a lot
of training with with myself you've been
on the crash course I know then you came
and found your patch and everything on
the extravaganza on the DfE but talk me
through how you chose the area if you
want to reveal the area you might want
to keep it secret but but at least the
principles of how you found the area is
it north south how did you find the
property taught me through the figures
and just in a lot of us as to how you
can literally leave as little as about
25 grand into a property and make such
massive returns
okay so we work across the north of
England so if you take a line from Hull
and bring that across the Liverpool this
there there is you know multiple areas
within that sort of patch yeah that we
operate in that within that as you know
as you know from your experience there's
certain towns in the cities which have
seen a lot of growth yeah the hotspots
and again nothing wrong with that at all
there is obviously demand but it means
you've got to be you know right right at
the top mmm for some places that's led
to a knock on in purchase prices with a
lot of people think they can pile in and
obtain a silly money so two things
happen number one we build a network so
that we get deals off market so we
insulate ourselves from the open market
craziness but you know secondly we find
locations which still fit all of the
right formulas for accessibility to the
big cities yeah but we use our creative
minds to find them in locations that
other people don't think of that's great
and that's why I said I know you've got
some very specific because sometimes an
area it's not just like home or
Liverpool it's almost sometimes there's
goldmine streets almost without question
yeah without question and it's about
really knowing which postcode work which
postcodes don't and that takes a lot of
due diligence
and the difference between making a you
making a 15-20 percent return and a 30
40 50 60 exactly and and what you've
done is you've spent a lot of time
finding that area as a result of
training and then just gone for it so
yeah but it's research it's hard work
people some people think that oh yeah
just rock up is easy no make no mistake
everything that we have and all of our
success is built on hard work both
treading the ground building the
relationship you know when you're the
kids at home you do a fantastic job the
research and just documenting everything
so we kind of interact as a team here
and play off each other strings that's
right
you know Sarah's got fantastic
organizational skills that's that's what
you do that's how it works
and I can be out there sometimes you
know with feet on the ground and yet you
know with the technology we have today
as well with mobile phones this
information is ebbing and flowing
everything flowing in real-time
you'll find a property say I'll just
show me this property they told me this
property is not on the books yet but
they're going to show it to me can you
find out so much information so I find
out how much it sold for last time what
are the prices in the area song for you
know how much rent we're likely to get
how much what we have best off for days
and within about 15 20 minutes max yeah
I ask you a question Sarah you very
interesting you say that where do you
draw a line between because and this is
something which I'm constantly trying to
get that balance with with more students
between due diligence and research and
spreadsheets which are really important
before you buy only think but then
sometimes a lot of people tend to have
what we call paralysis by analysis where
they they just get so bogged down by the
detail they're not viewing the
properties they're not playing offers
forward because I think I got one offer
forward until I know this but then the
thing this happened then how cells so
where do you what's the balance and the
tension between due diligence and being
very detailed because the devil is in
the detail but then at the same time
taking action and just going out and
putting offers on how do you balance
that say for us
in a decent property manager a property
managers have not only look after your
property but also tell you now don't go
down a street that's rubbish don't go
down a street but try these streets try
this area I've got people I want to put
in this area in this area I'm having
that information it's like gold dust
yeah because we men cut to the chase of
look lon we've actually can draw out a
plan or write new aware that we're
looking for properties and pinpoint
exactly where the houses only want to
look at and then Paul mr. Excel
spreadsheet man let's just provided a
spreadsheet that all I have to do is put
in certain figures how many bedrooms
it's likely to run out for HMO and then
how much profit we're likely to make on
each of those rooms and what they are is
gonna being that that's right as almost
red light green light at that stage it's
so basically what you're saying is you
do due diligence once yeah you don't
have to do it every time you see a house
you need to do this on an area or a hmm
management company and then you just
view properties that fit that criteria
and that's the other subtle thing is
that a lot of people may know their
contact we have very much taken that
relationship to another level of
absolute partnership but that takes time
to build a disaster under force what do
you mean by partnership it's just you
talk about with your HMO manager the HMO
managers absolutely yeah yeah so maybe
they're looking after us but I think you
know that so cry so all on all the
managers we you know we choose to work
with those people who can partner with
us that we can help them they can help
us and that that takes that relationship
to another level as opposed in just of
the transactional you know it goes
beyond that you know what it's really
refreshing to hear because a lot of
landlords and investors particularly hmm
landlord investors they just have such
high expectations and they treat
everyone like rubbish and you know that
if the HMO management company is not
fill in their rooms within within the
first two days they're bringing them why
are given in the rooms and what happens
is you become an island because you just
annoyed at you solicitor for being slow
and nor do the hmm management company
and and and you end up with a really
disjointed toxic power team that doesn't
work so
talk talk to me about that how do you
how do you deal with your with your
power team and how do you get the best
out of them being good human beings
being honest being you know do do what
you say you're gonna do when you win you
know when you declare you a lot of
people don't do that this is it but this
comes back to the point you made you
know you take an action there are things
you need to take action on yeah you know
so yeah in the last 24 hours we've had
interactions with all of our HMO
managers with all of our key
construction partners as well and all
the partners yes really cool oh it's
best to be yeah can only think that to
me to really work because yeah you can
go the transactional level that's fine
and you'll get deals at the
transactional level which will be you
know things that they might want to palm
on or move you know whatever make make
nice and simple yeah when something
interesting comes in when something
different comes in that's the
partnership level so which is on the
phone this morning driving up with our
with one of our agent partners yeah and
talking to this guy who we've built a
relationship up over a year and a bit
yeah and we need some very specific
information about what's going on with
this particular deal that we're looking
at where is that and we could have got a
partnership we're able to just share
things at a different level and that
gives you the insight so you can be a
skipper that's brilliant and I think
when you see everyone in your power to
him as a partner it's also got longevity
to it because it's not all we this list
or the agents salt the agent sold me a
house no no yeah just saw me house and
now we're partners and the agreement
that we have is they bring me off-market
deals and I buy them and we both get
money from examining what a great way to
look at it so can you talk me through
the figures I know you've even there's
two you've got two ones that have the
refinance has now come in you're on the
biggest you pull the money back yeah
give me give me the figures of just one
of them because if we try and do both of
them will talk I know they're both
brilliant but if we can just go with the
most juicy of the show I want the
figures I want to know shape so it fits
the criteria you spoke to High Command
management company yeah thought this
could be juicy give me the full details
I want the figures okay so this is a
was a 6 bed semi yeah family house or
was it opposite a park on probably one
of the prime streets yeah of which again
you move a quarter mile in other
directions or certain directions things
change a little bit quickly all of the
metrics the stainless stuff that we you
know you speak about the crash course
distances you know course all that all
that stacked up so snapped up from day
one yeah so this is you know this
location is 15 minutes from central
Liverpool it's got access to all modes
of public transport the six-bed semi was
a deal through an online agency at 180
okay so we bought it at 180 you paid so
we actually paid asking on a minute or a
minute yeah so not only are you treating
everybody in your power to him really
well you get you the belt and braces but
you're paying 100% asking prices for
houses so the right houses for the right
houses for the right house but again
it's just it's just busting the myths
the profitable landlords agreed it in a
constantly short clean everybody so
alright living the story so far so it's
all at 180 by four 180s assembled you
touch the property six bedrooms yeah 15
minutes from Liverpool city centre what
next
so then with our builder and agent
partners we've build up this picture
already from from day one you know and
it's I think this was a day trip up and
back in a day you did the exercise
actually had a viewer we have our
partner viewer who confused Proctor for
us because we are always able to go up
and view pop which is wrong and I'll
partner one up there and it does videos
for us and photographs and there's a
good detail description that you know if
you information form
and then we got all that back within an
hour I can do it and so you went up and
back in a day you live where South
Hamilton which is how many hours from
from from this house
four and a half so if so round trip
you're talking about what like almost 10
hours yeah which is insane all right so
then so you boiler has had to complete
so that this one work was a little bit
convoluted in that the way it was and
this is quite interesting the way the
house was set up before historically was
as flats and so there was a few
challenges around the finance so we had
to be resilient they didn't want to lens
because because you know multiple
kitchens so things that then become a
mortgageable in the traditional sense
okay so we follow the flexible finance
route with bridging okay
so we get that set up yeah we literally
we had to cross every hurdle put in
front of us in the purchase process I
think it's fair to say yeah the
financial case was one they select for
audit so every single piece of paper
that goes through the brokers desk the
finance company's desk
the solicitors desk has to be then
documented and tracked with this
parallel audit process as well and this
is what people don't understand it
sounds it easy sometimes you say on a
bridge the money yeah alright so in two
seconds to say it but it can take hours
and hours and hours of form filling out
and fighting and battling so in the end
how much money did you manage to bridge
to buy that 180 property so we bridge
that at 70% I think it wasn't in 70% 70
so you don't need to put on 30% which is
about what 50 grand
yeah alright so you put in about
approximately 50 grams yeah and then you
borrowed the rest how much interest
repaying on that bridge alone that was
0.95 a month yeah so you're talking
about 1112 percent a year which is not
bad no it is short term it shorts and
I'm sorry to put you on the spot with
all the things I should have warned
really love that some of my guys love
the figure so cliche and I'm glad that
you've got a good memory for the figures
so all right so you point about 50 grand
and you borrow the remaining hundred
thirty approximately and then what
so refurb pre pre the refurb yeah by
working with our agent partner and our
build own building partner
our initial designs of what it could
become we tweaked and changed and so we
there was an established demand for some
larger units so in the top floor of this
property what could have been for small
pokey rooms or at least two pokey rooms
and two regular rooms we decided to
knock a wall through here and put a door
in here and put a bathroom in here it's
fun yeah that's great
it's great that appeals to life on a
visual side yeah but we then we made the
top floor into two one-bedroom lounge
bathroom Suites
okay so that they're not full unit for
kitchens but they're what I call HMO
Suites yeah almost like a studio yeah
more the studio they were separated
bedrooms yeah we're in good condition
but just needed a lot of development on
it or was it a was it was it rundown as
well it looks in the photos yeah but why
we actually got into other baby
completely at five o'clock me we got in
there and the first kitten on the ground
floor basically covered in chicory skin
so how much was the full reverb so the
the refo came out just over 35 K all
right early 5k did you need to pilot
yourself well yeah you did yeah we did
so you put in about 85,000 pounds of
your own money yeah even part of the
money from someone no this is this so
your own money you put 85 grand into the
deal yeah now if someone said but I
haven't got eighty five grands just
borrow it from somebody right because
you guys know you keep looking like
you're in a situation where you know
you've been with a reasonably successful
business you had 85 grand in savings
yeah good for you but you could have you
could have borrowed that from somebody
so tell me what next so you spend 35
grand 50 grand on the deposit so far 85
groaning and what think then what so
refurb finishes up yeah and our
wonderful HMO agent says yeah we've got
a crowd of people moving in because I've
got a great connection into a local care
business and they've got six people
coming over on this day but then we go
mmm
job done so you rent the whole thing out
so so so so here's the deal we so we
chose at this point to go and license at
six runs yeah okay nobody spoke about on
the phone I spoke a lot about this yeah
yeah yeah so six rooms um pretty much
day one when it was ready to go people
in so how much rent is that getting
there then that property are crikey
that's you putting on the support I
can't I can't rock were offered off the
top of my head but let I know that the
the top suites are knocking on the door
are 600 quid a month Liverpool 15
minutes from I'm saying what the house
for 180 yeah and you renting out these
little things for like closer to 600
mm-hm so and how many rooms so those are
two tops weeks and we got fourth weeks
down below four rooms down below so
roughly do you know what the rent is
like like throughout the base about 400
on the others so was that one two there
2,800 they're right there
about so the rent is about 2500 hich a
month yep
now that's what that room seven oh so
the next phase now we're coming through
the refinancing to get planning for
sweet generous yeah to increase the the
license to take into account this other
room which is a present a sort of quasi
community space yeah but we've already
got other community spaces and we've got
two kitchens in play and we've got two
bathrooms yeah in in the main areas as
well so you've got a seventh seventh row
7th room which they so you stick another
four on top of that so so one how much
will it cost to do that it'll cost 450
for planning
it'll cost whatever it is I care do you
get the furniture so you're talking
about probably a thousand pounds hot
that's incredible which means that
you're then going to be bringing in a
total weight of about 3,200 yeah and you
know that you'll get it because the
other six rooms are rented out like that
I mean people say I hate you most
saturated I mean if you do them right
they're not no that's right if you're if
you're the high-end yeah there are
locations in the north right now that
are part of the telling us they they are
crying for runs as the house being
valued yet yes I'm what so you bought it
for 180 spent 35 on it so you spent
about
what 215,000 away not all of you of that
was your memento
85 was yours so 215 was how much she
paid including the refit what's it worth
now the valuation market right now is
challenging waiting for exit not gone
through that a lot of uncertainty and
valuers are definitely catching colds
yeah and the damp I mean and there's no
value in so I mean we got to 15 for it
so only that she's a witch with a shock
to us yeah we were hoping for more than
that absolutely okay so there's a bit of
a shock well I think certain what we can
do is that you know I think once we get
through the breaks it quite and the very
would just just absolutely stated this
is a situation that's occurring yeah
that's a reality and I'm not gonna blame
one thing or another it is what it is
yeah so okay great take on the chin fair
enough so it's right up to 15 which
means that you're going to end up
believing how much in numbers now cuz
we've been a bit creative how we how we
fill it finish financing all right
so can take too much about that but
we'll leave we're gonna leave around
about 3035 maybe tops in on that right
okay and I think I know what you're
doing but that's uh alright so so
basically then you've bought a property
for 180 a you have added fifty thousand
or you've spent $50,000 you've then
refined that stick creatively your leave
which Inc as much money as you can
I'm getting money then in our hands left
for the next deals and then you went out
for 3,200 but then after you bills and
you costs and stuff yet you left me with
around about two thousand pounds profit
a month yeah
believing in 30 grounds here very very
impressive that's awesome so what have
you learned from this then the most
important thing and how can you gotta
get at parity if you don't have your
parenting say to my manager and all the
guys that do the work for you
it's not just about getting them to do
the work it's getting by trust and their
trust in you not just your trust in them
and looking after them make sure you
take that for a meal you know buy more
drink it's you know how would you like
to be treated by somebody else it's how
you have to treat other people what
smell sorry what's your strongest reason
for doing this now doctor that what's
going versity just won't be financially
free
we haven't both run our businesses but
and we're very happy what we're doing
but equally by doing property we're
taking the pressure off ourselves so
once we are like fully financially free
we would still continue helping other
people not necessarily for it for a
money perfect when we spoke last year I
know when you started doing the training
you both told me that 2019 was going to
be your year of financial freedom and
then 2020 was going to be your year of
ultimate financial freedom if you want
to maybe just define what the difference
is so obviously a lot of very personal
reasons to talk about this because you
know I lost my father very you know
decades too early to cancer however he
was very fortunate to be successful and
by you
perhaps salute hard work coming into a
business as an apprentice and ending up
as the owner through actually graft and
grind with able to write you know I
think retire he was financially free in
his late 40s I'm in my late 40s and his
a date which is next February which is
our aiming point so that we can then
choose to do the things that we want to
do you know in the same way my dad
that's always been a drive for me it's
always been there for for many many many
years so that gets us to a point a I
think then point B our world what we
call ultimate or abundant financial
freedom is not only to do the things we
want to do when we want to do it and
choose to do the things we want to do
but we we both got give back projects
that we're really keen to put into place
mmm you know when you start you talk
about
the white hair from the crash course you
talked during that about giving back you
do your charity work what can we do and
one thing that's close to my heart worth
what if yours is in our last my sister
six years ago she was saying in hospital
but my parents have to travel to every
day to go and see her and it was a case
of if we could buy even if it's a
one-bedroom flat near a hospital we can
furnish it out and provide food and
drink and just have it as a go-to place
for somebody to go and stay with a
partner partner or family members and a
hospice or near the end of their days so
they don't have that pressure and stress
of traveling for a long time in between
the hospital visiting and there wouldn't
be any church it would be all right
under yourself in the hospital is why
you've had some things I don't know
though my kidney removed in March
that's quite an expenses yeah just from
working the infection discovering that
it wasn't working properly yeah okay
matter-of-fact about it needs to come
out it's going to better for it now I
mean you know not where you want to be
ultimately financial aid because you've
got these two really profitable houses
you've got a lot we're going to throw
that the bottom line is is there money
that you're making on property would be
but for most people would be enough to
be able to pay for bills yeah I've ever
normal living so what you do is is is
remarkable what's the year been like
working with me know well I loved it
loved it so all I can say every time
we've had a training event with the
South directly or you know some of the
wonderful people that you've been able
to get in front of us as a group just
and sleep because all this stuff is our
brains yeah and they're actually come
back at the crash course and we shared
in support of the crash course it was so
much parting in our heads and we were
staying in the same hotel over at the
NEC as the crash girls
we were both awake at heart 5:00 in the
morning and we chose to Nick down to the
hot tub at 6:00 a.m. going
and all this stuff that was everything I
had work with us we will start the
process fire I think they lit a fire and
we've always loved property and lit the
fire so yeah this is something we're
really really interested in one lane
gonna learn so much about it hmm
being part of a group of like-minded
individuals all of whom have the same
trajectory same aiming point and the
support that you know yourself and your
great team do give it's absolutely
nothing and it's not all smooth Simon I
know you know you guys have had
stressful times even within property
where things aren't working and it's
Paul but but having a support group of
people that you can talk to is I think
something that's really borne so it's
now if enabled us I mean we always say
with with the thing that we do is that
you know hTML is our thing and we
wouldn't be relentless in that providing
high quality HMOs are our thing we're
gonna be relentless in that we provide
really high quality properties for our
private sourcing network will relentless
in there they're just a few things we're
going to be relentless at yes and that's
it of the tronic grab every shiny object
that because you see a lot of your
friends who've also been on my crash
course and done training I do it totally
different stuff and they're killing yeah
is it sometimes hard to say you know
what I've got a good friend he was on
the same programs logging on he was
absolutely killing it but understand
when zone is that sometimes hard and
it's just no fun because that's yeah
that's their there they're driving their
train yeah you know that's not our
trainer drive and ours isn't they're
trying to drive yeah so that's
absolutely yeah absolutely fine by us so
we always keep in mind open to other
opportunities we're now in a class okay
like we're only doing HMOs
yeah of course but it's about being
focused sometimes you need to be focused
because if you try and do everything and
do nothing like the amount of work that
goes into just putting a powell team
together and building a patch it's a lot
of work you bet let's do it properly and
just do a bit of this and a bit of that
you know something that really irritates
me on winners Wednesday is occasionally
people comment on this and they try and
justify I think it's like a
justification of why they aren't able to
do that so they'll say oh well you have
the 85 grand that were you either and
it's like every week I interview someone
a winner on a Wednesday from a
completely different background
sometimes they could have been homeless
most people will always try and find all
that it's different for me oh I can't do
it because of this and I think you just
need to just deal take the cards you've
been dealt and just yeah there's always
a strategy I mean have you made talked
to me about some of the friends that
you've made through the training who who
and some of the you know stories and
stuff that's going on there well it was
lovely
I have to say in the picture after the
lovely Leslie tau and her young son yeah
that was we sort with I saw that picture
on her face yeah yeah beautiful moment
asking people cuz you know we've known
Leslie from pretty much from day one
yeah Alistair we were on the same DfE
course you have the same difficult
Alistair's he's doing that he's doing
that whole world of great stuff yeah so
we love that so we've made just some you
know some fantastic connections and
friendships great some across the way
some of whom have come to become you
know partners in a wider sense with us
who we work very very closely together
with other Academy members in that in
that space we've had Rex the work with
Rex has been awesome as well yeah yeah
one of the mentors on the Academy yeah
so you're you're happy with how the last
12 months has gone there yeah that's
been going on play hard and that's great
as well he's even just coming away on on
you know some of the training courses we
make that part of our downtime as well
so yeah
so we're learning we're growing here and
then we take time out to spend time with
each other as well
what would your advice be to someone
watching this that was thinking I really
want that I've got a little poem and I
really want to invest it they want to
get as much return as they can where
should I start I think I wouldn't want
to say to somebody to start here or
there but find your thing
mmm find your thing and do it now yeah
and then do more of it and more of it
than do more of it so find your niche
find your thing push it for all it's
worth
yeah love that how about you Sarah how
do you find a property money when you
found your patch find a property manager
do research type map recover Cox I'm
adding something to it yeah and I get to
know that person because if that person
is interested in investing in you then
you've got to be interested investing in
that person always guys only think about
the department ship yes I was so
important and it's just been an absolute
boost to our journey so far what would
you say to someone that was weighing up
whether to come to the crash course but
was feeling a bit unsure what would your
advice be first hand you might feel you
know I'm not sure I should do this all
its gonna cost me loads of money but I
open your mind open your ears up go
along with samuels exercises because it
will take away it comes for saying but
you learn some it's just open keep your
mind open there are a lot of people who
who don't have the open mind it's just
not interested in learning you but I
wasn't initially but don't bother after
they give me more give me more
information Oh
it's just gone from there yeah but you
Paul yeah what's it a loose yeah you
know I mean I mean we paid to come on
your crash course yeah I think it was
back in the day when it was tuned into
town yeah we paid a company crash and
now it's for now it's free so there is
absolutely nothing to lose
yeah and just the world to gain if you
choose to open your mind to the
opportunities that presented in front of
you love that well thank you ever so
much for sharing your story it's been a
blast working with you and look forward
to seeing you succeed more and gonna do
wonderful things absolutely break before
thank you okay thank you so much for
watching the video that is the reason
why I'm doing this your success is my
oxygen every single week we've got
people becoming financially free if
you'd like to see more success units you
can do that right here but what I'd
really suggest is why don't you come and
join us
at the property investors crash course
come on on my guest completely free and
I'll personally be there for two days to
help you get started you can see what
happens right here what you'll notice is
all of these stories they all start at
the crash course so come along my guests
can't wait to see you there
peace out